Chairman's chaplain and the managing
director public please remain standing
for prayers let us pray
gracious and loving God tonight each of
us come with those different concerns of
our communities on our hearts and Lord
we pray for wisdom we pray for that
ability to hear one another in all that
he said father we pray that you would
help all those informed in the
decision-making process to come to a
common mind we pray for unity and for
respect we pray gracious Lord that your
good and perfect will would be done this
evening father we offer unto you our
communities our families and we thank
you for that privilege of being those
here that represent you and represent
them so gracious Lord in all that is
done this evening we pray that you'd be
honored and that you'd be glorified in
our midst
please be seated
like one of the gender members we have
apologies are there any other apologies
no cute item to the minutes of the
meeting held on the 11th of December
2018 are there green members item three
declarations of interest no thank you
for announcements from the chairman
leader or head of page service I would
really like to say that since the last
meeting I have attended a number of
quite a number of events and functions
and I will be more than happy to list
them but it would might take some time
suffice to say that I enjoyed many cowls
during December and I think I've almost
WordPerfect on most of them I've
attended some very nice dinners and the
very moving Holocaust memorial service
which was attended by the Lord
Lieutenant of Essex
and also the seventh 70th anniversary
service at Basildon which was also very
interesting I was particularly impressed
by the Essex wing Air Training Corps
awards ceremony and I would most
impressed with their discipline
smartness and attention to detail I'll
now move to item five on the agenda the
public questions and members on notice
there are none business from last
council meeting there is none item 7 to
note the minutes of executive and
committee meetings held between the
period 1st December 2018 and 31st
January 2019 as listed they noted
members kill now move on to item 8
and I think councillor step so you will
be presenting on that thank chairman I'm
not sure that your microphone is
actually working chairman I think it is
I moved my chair I'm in my chair forward
leg gentleman this item was referred by
the investment board on the 16th of
January to Council with recommendations
relating to approval of the OBC and the
adp as chairman of the Investment Board
I'm pleased to speak on this report the
OB C's product of the council's assets
strategy this strategy has a clear
vision to reduce the future running
costs associated with the council's
assets generate capital receipts to help
fund future investment bring forward an
optimum optimized asset base that is fit
for purpose and for the twenty twenty
first century operations
enable quality service delivery for
residents and visitors through a
sustained program transformational this
project has seen officers and members
working together on a complex critical
project in order to bring Ford clear
proposals to deliver the council's
objectives through a highly integrated
delivery program across the council's
key strategic assets I would like to
thank the officers and the working party
that put a great deal of work into this
and spent many hours on this project
therefore chairman I move the
recommendations in the report as printed
on page eight point one point three item
two point one thank you we'll have a
seconder Thank You Johnny
chairman I like the second net and also
have the right to come back after the
debate thank you
Thank You chairman I read the report and
I too would like to thank all the
officers and the working party that been
involved with this um I'm a resident too
I'm not just a counselor as are all of
us in this room tonight and I'm hearing
rumblings that this project of moving
the counter chamber is gonna cost the
taxpayer millions which is clearly
incorrect but can we just have some
clarification that place chairman
thank you um yeah so the outline
business case is presented as part of
this report to sit out the financials
for the project and it's estimated at
this stage of the project that there
will be a net capital requirement of
naught point six million pounds
obviously that's a net requirement so
the intention I set out in the business
case is that proceeds from the capital
receipts from some of the sites would
cross subsidize the building of the new
facility at the freight house but the
it's correct that at this stage they
would just be a net funding cost of not
twenty six million
councillor pistoi
thank you so much ah thank you
I I'm not a member of your basement but
I have attended I think all the ratings
related to this and I think I've said in
that meeting I do have concerns about
the about this business case and the way
this is an hour-long business class it's
not yet a full business case and I do
understand that however I think perhaps
I may or may not I'm not sure what
counsel mrs. Rowe was referring to but
I've got Caesarea we are using assets
worth knee three million pounds to
provide it's essentially an office at
the freight house which may have
additional commercial property but I I
still haven't been convinced or see
anything to convince me that spending
2.8 million pounds of our money in that
way is the best use of those assets or
the money that we can realize from those
assets and I do have problems with what
the route this business case is taking
in how it will end up so that's really
active clinical microphones around that
thank you thank you that's Reeves so if
I have those the wrong way around
thank you
the the project is a large one in
relation to projects undertaken by the
council in the past if we as accounts a
lot to pursue this project while I don't
have any major concerns with a strategic
outline case I do have a number of
concerns with the outline business case
I have Building Industry qualifications
many years of first-hand experience
working in the industry at the level of
this venture is projected to be at as
such I have questioned that the
investment board committee the approach
being pursued by officers and the member
working party with regards to the best
risked stroke financial risk route
proposing that we partner with a company
to take this on my experience of the
trade is that this the success of a
project is not down to the company
but down to the project contracts
manager and the team he pulls in to work
on the project to claim that the risk is
lowered by partnering with the company
is in my experience a fallacy the fact
is that a building contract is only a
reduced risk if you have the best person
running it not the best company on paper
I am familiar with the internal workings
of building companies that operate in
this level of construction I can assure
you that even though they may be told we
may be told that they have been vetted
and are considered sound that they are
very good at hiding their problems I
remind the council of the Karelian
debacle conversely any problems that
come to light in-house would be able to
be dealt with and they would be in the
light below the total figure the product
for the project is large the sums are
made up by the joining of a number of
smaller building projects not one big
one so the complexities lent more
towards one of organization not
complicated building methods the skills
required to run the projects are
infinitely available to be successfully
brought in-house I was initially
surprised considering the council's
current appetite for setting up their
own businesses when the in-house option
although it was talked about has never
really been given serious consideration
the reports presented to us at the
Investment Board to my mind read from
the point of making the report match the
decision rather than giving serious
consideration to other options such as
the in-house option as I've said earlier
my experience in the trade is that far
from minimizing the risk by going down
the partnership route the risk is
exactly the same the difference is that
by going down the partnership with the
council is giving away a large amount of
money to the partner company the
question then has to be in this time of
tight finances at Council are we
prepared to sign away the large amount
of money we would be losing to bolster
the partnership company's profits which
is pretty much all we will achieve by
going down the route that this council
is being steered thank you
Casa Gianna Gipe did you say would you
like to come back sorry
chairman members officers as portfolio
holder for enterprise I welcome the
opportunity to speak in support of this
report the asset delivery program is a
highly integrated program that will
bring forward an optimized asset base
and deliver the objectives of the
council's assets tragedy given the scale
of the program
the council has sought the advice of
experts support officers throughout the
process a prudent and sensible approach
the outline business case has been
completed with rigor due diligence with
strong input from the member working
party which like to say thank you very
much for their hard work thank you very
much but I didn't want to jump in front
of accounts to just vote just to say I
think then what councillor Reeves was
told if that was actually considered
that are quite rightly that the
Investment Board that we had we are not
a Metropolitan Borough normally a county
we were a Versailles where we have to
seek the pilk from other parties and we
need the right help and I think in the
parties that we've actually consulted so
far we've had that right help chairman I
think if members referred to 11 to which
refers to revenue costs and remembering
that this is an outlying business case
so it's not the full business case we've
got to proceed to that so we're not
there yet
but it does say the estimated revenue
costs the preferred scheme i mean--can
compared against the do minimum option
as summarized in the table below and if
the members look just above level living
- there was a table there this
demonstrates the preferred option could
generate ongoing annual annual revenue
savings in excess of 300 thousand pounds
per annum for the council compared to
the to minimum option this is based on
the assumption that the council's future
revenue costs under the new minimum
option would increase from current
annual expenditure levels in order to
maintain the current obviously
datian recognized industry standards so
chairman we need to spend some money on
our buildings in any event and some of
our buildings are very ancient in fact
some of them go back to the 13th century
but having said that chairman that
obviously is no longer used so I think
if you look at that and you also look at
the table under eleven five which shows
the capital funding I think what we're
actually planning and taking forward is
quite imaginative I think it will
provide officers in in the right place
at the right time for our residents and
for our staff in a modern environment
because what we have unfortunately is is
aging fast and needing money spending on
it so I think I'd like to thank all
those involved in this and especially
the working group that they've taken
this forward but I just repeat chairman
but once this is finished
are we looking at that 300,000 pounds
which I think is very important thank
you thank you thank you can I just point
out one thing that the cost savings that
counselor cut more is talking about they
would be achieved whichever route we
went what I was trying to highlight is
that the route that the council is being
steered is actually going to cost the
council a lot more money to do the build
when Council cut more pointed out that
we did consider the option of self-build
when we went through committee it was
quite early on dismissed and I had some
severe reservations that I did make
clear in the committee and there were
other members who did recognize that at
the time thank you no other members
showing the recommendation is that it is
proposed that council resolves
mrs. Macpherson Thank You chairman just
one question
um obviously a gambeson councillors has
there been any intent of review it into
this some business cases yeah thank you
thank you
yeah we've taken independent and
specialist advice and on the way we've
commissioned experts in the field to
help us prepare the business case so
we're confident that we have taken the
necessary expertise and we have recently
been through an independent review of
which details of that will be released
to due course as well so that weren't
ready in time for this report but we
have we have taken independent assurance
and along the way as well
Thank You chairman just out of interest
who is this independent group just so we
know their accreditation thank you ah
sir step sir Thank You chairman that's
exactly what I was just going to say the
report the report has been carried out
by Gateway a sword review by local
partnership organised jointly and owned
by HM Treasury and the LGA
we'll now then move to the
recommendation and it is proposed that
council resolves one that they kept the
outlined business case for the asset
delivery program as set out in Appendix
A be approved and published with
appropriate production and secondly that
a further two hundred ninety eight
thousand two hundred pounds be drawn
down from general balances to fund the
resources required to progress the
program to full business case stage is
that agreed members my vote be recorded
against on both counts please do you
wish me to take a vote rather a vote yes
if that's possible thank you well yeah I
mean I'm happy sympathy to record
vocalist that thing take it
mr. Samsa they wanted to speak no
is it just to record that you were
against all right let me take a vote for
the avoidance of doubt that all those in
favor please show
Thank You those against
they were good kids
that is carriage we now refer proceed to
item 8 to the report of the planning
policy subcommittee and I think
councilís Thank You chairman lead on
that the planning policy subcommittee
held a meeting on the morning of the
31st of January and the report that has
been circulated to members I believe is
a true and accurate record of what took
place at that meeting there were two
items that were required to be referred
to the full council excuse me with
recommendations one was the local plan
local development scheme 2018 to 2021
and the subcommittee's recommendations
in relation to this item are on page
eight point two point two and there was
also an item issue relating to gypsy and
travelers issue paper and substantive
ility appraisal regulation 18
consultation with the subcommittees
recommendations in respect of this issue
on pages eight point two point four at
eight point two point five and I submit
those to fall Council so thank you Jim
aconite before you start are you going
to be speaking on the first item no I'm
going to speak on the second one
can-can I deal with the first item
certainly except for a few things so if
we take the first item and the
recommendation is that the council
resolved that the draft local
development schemes 2018 to 2021 be
adopted all those in favor
and against that's a that's approved
thank you yeah well move move to the
second part councillor Ward Thank You
chairman I would like to propose that
this consultation is withdrawn
I believe this delay will give the
council time to fully digest and
understand all the implications to
enable us to prepare a plan that
reflects the balance required between
the diverse needs within the Gypsy and
traveler community and the concerns of
the majority of the residents that
comprise the settle community in this
district thank you Jim do I have a
seconder council Steptoe
yes German I'm happy to second that and
I'll take the right to speak at the end
of the debate council mr. Mason thank
you very much chairman I'm a member of
that subcommittee so I'd like to ask
councillor Ward what's changed since
that subcommittee meeting because I've
been advised of nothing and given that
nothing has changed I will not be
supporting withdraw of the public
consultation because no one has told me
why in the second place at that
subcommittee I asked the Managing
Director why the council had been unable
to take any positive steps to bring
Mitchell Innes farm forward as a
permanent travelers site and he
suggested then I bring the matter up at
full council well I'm doing so and
through you chairman I'm directing that
question as well to council award as
portfolio holder for planning thank you
councillor Ward Thank You chairman as we
recognized there were two sites that
were withdrawn which has changed the
actual consultation completely we know
that there are another two sites that
are going to be subject to inspection we
also have I believe there's a planning
application at Mitchell Ian's farm which
may have a bearing on it
so with these particular planning
processes I believe together with the
documentation which has come from
central government or gypsy and
travelers which I have have been reading
we need to go back and understand fully
bringing our consultation forward with
that included that is why I'm asking
urging this council to withdraw this
consultation at the moment so that we
can present it later thank you cows
amazing second part of my question has
not been answered chairman as far as
that is concerned they all refer to the
measure director please you asked him so
Jim chairman mayor come back can I
reiterate please because it's not been
understood councillor Ward was present
along with others at the subcommittee
meeting announced that very same
question of the managing director who
declined to answer saying please ask for
counsel clearly there's no point in
asking the managing director again
because he didn't wasn't able to answer
it on that occasion so I'm directing the
question to the portfolio holder for
planning who should know the answer if
there is a cogent reason why we've been
unable to bring that site forward
[Music]
there are planning applications coming
forward on those sites therefore as far
as I'm concerned we need to look at
everything in relation to that thank you
for that good answer your question
chairman it's an answer it is not an
answer which I think answers the
question I put but nevertheless the
public are here the members are here and
in due time so will the inspector who
looks at this particular part of our LD
f Thank You chairman thank you
canta Stanley Thank You chairman it's
obvious that since 2014 we've been
discussing this mission in saw it for
the travelers and it seems to be taking
a long long time with no resolution
whatsoever and here I find that we are
waiting for cooperation from two other
districts in a report which was or which
is an update at 2019 and yet we still
got though nowhere to go when are we
going to and I ask that to the portfolio
older when are we going to get this so
it because while we're not getting this
site and not made a decision in this
chamber they will forever lost in using
up Greenbelt which we don't really want
so I ask the question
wait will we be getting this site off
their ground bags not off of other
councils thank you do you wish to
respond to that councillor Ward I think
I responded earlier on as far as that
was concerned we are at this moment
looking at sites at the moment
Michelin's farm is our core strategy
choice it is the site that is designated
for gypsy and travelers which is in our
allocations and as far as I'm concerned
that is the site that is designated
thank you
counter government Thank You chairman
just one thing I'd like to clarify for
both members and members of the public
is that the sites that we were looking
at so we were invested in looking at
within the consultation or not sites
that have been put forward by this
council they are sites that have been
forward by put forward by members of the
public by landowners and businesses that
own land in the district and they have
put that land forward and we are obliged
at a certain stage to actually consult
the public on how we take that forward
they are not sites that we have chosen
to put forward I just want to clarify
that because it has been said elsewhere
that these are sites that have been put
forward by this council well that's not
the case
thank you thank you chairman Cantus
Terry you did do you want to come back
on a point of clarification thank you
Thank You chairman designated sites are
all very well but when are we going to
make that site a site not designated we
continue to do so since 2014 and if we
continue to do this we could be in 2024
but only get your answer on that you may
not be happy no no I want to know what
designated actually means please
chairman counter mr. Hoya thank you
Kevin sorry to drag out machines farm
again I understand the answer well I
understand words that constable were
walled used I'm not sure careful makes
mr. Mason said to the actualities
question good um first of all he
mentioned he doesn't think it's a viable
I'm not sure the word to use I don't put
words in his mouth a site we should go
forward with at the moment because the
Planning Commission's have may be coming
forward obviously this site has been the
designated site for some time and I
think the question is why why hasn't it
been moved forward with earlier and is
it that the landowner is getting so fed
up with our failure to do so that
they've been forced to find other uses
for the land and that's why they're
putting planning applications forward
did you want to respond to the best of
my knowledge Mitch and his farm has been
sold there is a new owner who I believe
is putting in planning permission on
that site there was the concerns I
believe when the inspectors were looking
at the site that there was little chance
of it coming forward there it would seem
to me with a new owner and the site
being cleared there is a better chance
of it coming forward okay we have a
proposal to withdraw the this particular
report and it has been seconded did you
want to come back counter steps oh thank
you Thank You chairman I don't think
there's anything I further I can add
other than to say what we do need to
wait for this planning application to
come forward until we've received that
we're talking hypothetically here's a
lot at the time okay Casper mountain
thank you sorry
just come back to airman I did ask to be
the last speaker
I will it was as you stood up that I saw
counselor Mountain raise his hand but
I've
I think I've got to allow you to speak
it thank you is this this would be the
last paper if you wanted to come back
after which council award has asked for
this to be withdrawn till later this
wondered if there was a time period on
what later when this is likely to come
back the only thing that we say is when
the work is completed when we've looked
all the various things when we look at
items one two and three and the
questions are on there can't a step down
there are no other questions no other
comments - thank you Thank You chairman
as I've already said we've got to wait
for this planned application to come
forward there's a lot of work that's got
to be done behind the scenes to really
understand what all the implications are
including what government to bring him
forward with their travel and drip-free
requirements so all of that needs to
come to a fruition in fullness of time
to put a time leaning on it it's going
to be very difficult
thank you Jim so the proposal and has
been secretary seconded is that this
report be withdrawn is that agreed
members very well I will put it to a
vote if that is the wish all those in
favor of withdraw those against
Thank You Sonia thank you that's
withdrawn say we'll proceed now to item
u9 report on urgent decisions there are
none and item 10 reported the leader on
the work of the executive councilor
colonel thank you very much chairman
this is the fourth ordinary council
meeting of the 2018-19 municipal year
and i would like to welcome all members
since the meeting on the 11th of
december the executive has met once
which considerations included the
quarter three 2018-19 Financial
Management a performance report and the
latest position on the council's key
performance indicators approving the
transfer of six hundred thousand pounds
of budget the in year under spend to the
local development fund reserve to
increase the funds for planning policy
work to support the delivery of the
local plan joint strategic plan and
related to level deployment talks a
development plan documents over the next
five years delegating authority to the
assistant director Environmental
Services in consultation with the
portfolio holder for environment to
approve the in avert community grant
award of forty five thousand pounds for
player equipment a great waiting open
space and the consequent
execution of the project noting the
arrangements being made to secure the
long-term visitor potential of Wallasey
Island including an event in May 20-22
the council's discover 2020 festival
agreeing the ongoing procedures were
allocating voluntary sector grants fund
for the financial year 2019 twenty and
noting that the process aligns the
outcomes with local strategic priorities
as detailed in the council's business
plan and the joint Rochford and cars to
point health and well-being strategy
agreeing that the Railly rots from the
district Association for voluntary
services we receive top sliced funding
from the
same pot based on performance as the
community connector and experts other
matches might 60 colleagues and I have
dealt with include improving the formal
response to Buzzard on Borough Council's
consultation on its local plan
publication draft regulation nineteen
agreeing the brownfield Land Register
December twenty 2018 be accepted into
the council's evidence base and
published on the council's website as
always chairman I will be happy to take
any questions from members in respect of
the work of the executive and I'm sure
my executive colleagues we're going to
be happy to it contribute where
appropriate Thank You chairman council
mr. Mason thank you I'd last like to ask
a question about the local plan budget
if you like it's been it's been referred
to by the leader in the fact of
transferring six hundred thousand pounds
under spend to the LDF reserve it talks
about five years what does the council
expect to spend in total including money
spent to date on the new local plan
please
if you'd like to look at take a look at
the medium-term strategy I believe it's
in there and the last meeting we had
chimp with we have our financial officer
i-15 one officer here
I don't recall seeing that figure can't
you please tell us what the figure is
please for the total spend from the
inception which was a year or so ago to
the end of the five unit how much we're
going to spend please on the local plan
a new local plan thank you thank you
and so our best estimate of the total
spend at the moment is in the region of
about one point also just under a
million pounds and so we have already
had got some reserves set aside and
which will help fund that and this will
help obviously bolster the funds that
are required but I would say at this
stage it's quite early in the process
and we don't have necessarily a real
clear indication of the total spend at
this stage but that's our best
estimation at the moment I would say all
it does as part of the financial
strategy that we've presented we have
taken significant ongoing revenue budget
out of the ongoing based budget from
1920 onwards so this fund is to support
the works which would otherwise be
implanted for the revenue budget wishes
and a blast to set a balanced budget
going forward thank you
so said we haven't got an absolute and
perfect Essen at this stage but we're
working on the assumption it would be
just under a million pounds cancel
company chairman just to add to that
don't forget we're also proceeding with
the joint strategic plan with other
authorities which we hope to gain a
significant infrastructure investment
and we in all of South Essex not just
roads etc we're talking about other
things as well that everybody needs so
that's all part of our plans coming
forward - thank you you know the
questions then we can pass to the next
item which is item 11 emotions on notice
there are none now I've maybe some
members of the public who have come
along for a specific item on the agenda
which we've now passed if they wanted to
leave please this would be a convenient
time to do so okay item 12 setting the
council text 2019 to 2020 council couple
gemenon through you counselors members
of the public and press this is my 15th
budget as leader of the Conservative
administration the budget pressures
under which local government operates
remain significant and this authority to
continues to look closely opportunities
to make efficiency savings and generate
new sources of revenue this is not only
in response to the removal of government
grants but also to deal with significant
cost increases arising from inflationary
and democratic demographic pressures
looking to the future will be refreshing
our business plan that sets out the
high-level priorities that the council
will work towards over the medium term
this will incorporate the council's
plans to deliver an asset program which
aims to maximize the value from the
council's key strategic sites our
current priorities that set out in the
2016 2020 plan are to become financially
self-sufficient to use early
intervention to manage demand on our
services to maximize our assets and to
enable communities despite the funk to
the challenges faced we have continued
to deliver excellent services to our
residents as achievements over the past
year include being placed joint second
in the league for reciting out of more
than 350 local authorities across
England hosting a wedding fairer and an
us wedding venue the old house Oxford on
the 20th of May our 15th annual wild
woods day which took place on the 14th
of July at Hockley woods where visitors
had a chance to try their hand at
activities and stroll around the pop-up
marketplace continuing to provide local
business with advice and support
including hosting various business
breakfasts adopting the environmental
health service plan mandatory child
sexual exploitation awareness training
for Oxford District Council taxi drivers
in July August and September becoming a
hate incident reporting centre where
members of the public can be assisted to
report a hate incident or crime
as a responsible council we will
continue to look at areas where costs
can be reduced or income generated
however in 2019-20 there is a need to
increase council tax by two point nine
eight percent to help fund the financial
pressures that the district is currently
facing this equates to an increase of 13
pence per household per week on AB and D
property the repose will is to set
Rochford district council tax for AB and
E property at 230 pounds 31 pence per
year the breakdown of annual council tax
for AB and E property would be Essex
County Council 1179 pound 63 Essex
County Council social care levy 90
pounds and 81 pence Essex County Council
Fire and Rescue 70 pounds 38 Essex
police fire and crime Commissioner 192
pounds 96 the average town and parish
council is 48 pounds and 66 and rots for
district count so as I've said is 230
pounds and 31 pence the total average
council tax Revati property for 2019-20
will be one thousand eight hundred and
fourteen pounds and eighty two pence an
increase of Epicor pounds and 11 pins
that's approximately four point nine
percent in conclusion although these are
still difficult financial times Rochford
District Council remains committed to
providing excellent services to our
residents and partners with this in mind
we will be doing all we can to deliver
innovative and high quality services Jim
and I commend rocks for district council
text for members approval and thank you
Thank You chairman I would be fenugreek
obviously we discussed the budget last
week and members feel the know how much
I focus when it either comets are made
then I don't go on and on well said last
week obviously members from that will be
aware that I don't necessarily that we'd
say well run on HD in any weights
financially well run council I did point
out the inconsistencies on that in
relation to the ICT on
tracts in the ICT and capital budgets
and also in relation to what I would
regarded reserve a counting with 347
pounds in a legal reserve and I'm still
have no answer to whether there is a
legal case ongoing or not not like I say
so if there was I suppose so I have real
problems with the budget I don't but I
believe that there are significant sums
of money available in reserves which we
haven't made use of I believe the
suddenly the the ICT budget is now over
we're now paying more for the current
ICT contract than we were four the old
one and the new one was supposed to be
saving money I do have problems with it
and I still can't see how vital support
to annihilate the same team great on
that basis did you wish to come back on
that council mr. bass Thank You chairman
I'm not gonna go over any old ground
because I just heard the interesting
consolidation figure as being an
increase overall in council taxes and
precepts and everything of 4.9% whereas
of course we know that inflation is
running around less than half of that I
think it's about time government
actually decided to take a take a good
view across the whole spectrum of local
government and precepting and kept it to
a total of the rate of inflation rather
than inflation busting Chairman thank
you as there are no other members
indicating we have 10 items under the
recommendation I'm not going to read
them out all out individually unlike
last week none of the items require a
recorded vote so I can if members
approve take all 10 items together but
if you wish be twitted if you wish me to
take them individually I'm happy to do
so
then obviously well would have no
problem with in some other fair enough
in that case I will take them
individually I item one that the council
tax requirement for the council's own
purposes for twenty two twenty nineteen
to twenty excluding parish from town
precepts is seven million two hundred
and seventy thousand nine hundred and
fifteen all those in favor please show
all those against that's agreed item two
there the council tax requirement of the
council together with the parish and
Town Council's be eight million eight
hundred and seven thousand one hundred
and nine ninety four pounds for the same
period all those in favor please say
well there's against pre-show that is
agreed item three that the basic amount
of council tax including parish and to
town precepts be 278 pounds ninety-seven
for the year this being the council tax
requirement eight million eight hundred
and seven thousand eight 194 pounds
divided by the council tax base of
thirty one thousand five hundred and
seventy point for all those in favor
please show those against thank you that
is agreed item four that the total pair
of parish and town precepts included
within the above be one million 536,000
279 pounds all those in favor please
show those against
that is agreed item five there the basic
rate of council tax relation to the
council without parish and town precepts
be 230 pounds 31 which is a two point
nine eight percent increase all those in
favor pre-show
well--there's against thank you that is
a great
item six that the total tax for both the
council and the town and parish council
parishes councils be as set out in the
schedule in Appendix B all those in
favor please show and that against has
agreed item seven that the sums given
the buffer bandy be now shown in the
particular valuations bands a to H B as
set out in the schedule in Appendix C
all those in favor please show theirs
against that agreed item eight that the
precepts issued to the council in
respect of Essex County Council Essex
Police Fire and crime Commissioner and
Essex County Fire and Rescue Service for
each valuation band a to H B as set out
in the schedule in appendix D all those
in favor please show that against that's
agreed item nine nearly there
that the total council tax for the area
for each valuation band
8hb as set out in appendix E these are
the amounts that set as council tax for
the year twenty twenty twenty nineteen
to twenty twenty all those in favor
please show and cure there's against
they show as agreed item ten that the
total of the sums are payable into the
council's general fund in respect of
redistributed business rates surpluses
levy separate I beg your pardon said
levy surplus grant new homes bonus and
adjustments from the collection funds be
three million five hundred and seventy
four thousand nine hundred and seven
pounds all those in favor please show
and they're against thank you
that completes item 12
item 13 is the counterattacks empty
homes premium I think maybe you're going
to lead on that thank you and yes the
purpose of the report is to provide
members with proposals for increasing
the amount of the count stacks empty
homes premium charged on long-term NC
properties the local government Finance
Act 2012 amended previous legislation to
allow local authorities to levy a 50%
premium on properties which have been
unoccupied and substantially unfurnished
for two years or more it was agreed by
Council at its meeting on the 22nd of
October 2013 to introduce its premium
from the 1st of April 2014 and now
further legislation has been passed to
enable local authorities to increase the
amounts of premium levied the proposed
last assassin report is to increase to
100% from the 1st of April 2019
properties have been unoccupied and
unfurnished for two years or more and
from the 1st of April 2000 24 properties
have been unoccupied and substantially
unfurnished between five and ten years
yes two hundred percent and two three
hundred percent for properties that have
been unoccupied and unfurnished for 10
years or more from April 21 there's a
couple of statutory exemptions so if a
property is left empty by serving member
of the Armed Forces who's living
elsewhere an accommodation provided by
their Secretary of State for Defence and
that is exempt from this legislation and
also empty annexes
so yes their primary reason for the
change in policy is not financially
driven however it's possible and a small
amounts of additional income may be
generated for the council but the
overriding aim of the policy is to bring
empty homes back into use and as such
we've been working across the council to
try and bring empty homes back into use
wherever possible and so yeah that's
what I was going to say on this
recommendations Carol mr. Hoyer thank
you chairman Issa's Adams very welcome I
understand the difficulty of perhaps
assessing the financial implications of
it but as it says in the paragraph three
point three I think the the probably the
ultimate intake degrees bring homes into
use has there been any assessment of
family but additional homes might be
brought into use with this policy the
figure I've got at the moment for the
number of properties that are currently
facing the levy for under the current to
you well is the sixty five properties
but obviously the extension to the
legislation for properties have been
unoccupied for a longer period of time
won't come into force until they're
following financial years so we can't
give a reasonable estimate of what that
might be at that stage because obviously
our policy is to try and put those homes
back into you so every possible better
at the moment there's sixty five
properties that are subject to the live
thank you well those sixty-five
properties big or owners us be assisted
through other parts of the cases where
ie through through housing officers
tried to explain to them how this will
affect them on how they could perhaps
benefit themselves and other people who
are bringing in houses back into use as
well by carrot-and-stick in other words
yeah that's correct yes it says in the
report our private sector housing team
is working closely to identify and work
with those owners to try and be nice
properties back in tears
mr. casual mr. Mason Thank You chairman
there seems to be a very pivotal phrase
and that pivotal phrase is substantially
unfurnished I'd like to know what the
council's test is of substantially
unfurnished because clearly if there
isn't a very clear test about the
assessment then there's going to be
challenges and arguments and they could
prove more costly than the increased
revenue and well yeah obviously this is
a slightly gray area and I could
probably and take that question away and
get a more complete answer if you would
like but obviously the test does it set
out is it's substantially unfurnished
but obviously there is a judgement call
to be made from our officers in terms of
determining how that's implemented mrs.
Mason
mr. Chairman I believe my husband's
covered a point that I was going to ask
but I actually have asked the office so
it's substantially unfurnished means
because it is a point to the report that
concerned me now if the objective of
this report and this increased charge is
to bring empty homes into use then
obviously no one is not going to support
that but there is no legal definition of
substantially unfurnished it's
discretionary and the housing officer
that I spoke to said that last time an
increase was put in place what happened
was that people just put furniture into
the properties and then it became
substantially furnished now obviously
that's not something that we want to
happen and I wonder what steps the
officers and the council is going to
take to try to make sure that doesn't
happen at these homes are put back into
use for our residents thank him hmm
perhaps I can see a word or two about
that I mean I think it's a it's a good
point that's being made by councillor
mrs. Mason and I think what would we
want to do is to take that away and have
a have a think about that and and
circulate some information to all
members I think that I think that's
probably about the best we can do at
this at this this juncture but I think
the point is well made and it's one that
we need to give some further
consideration to
very related point is if the intent is
to bring back empty homes into use is
there a need for them to be both
unoccupied and unfurnished to some
extent is the criteria of being
unoccupied not enough and if not would
we be able to provide some clarification
as to why that's it thank you yeah well
I'd say is that we are operating within
the national legislative framework and
they are the ones that determine the
rules under which we operate so we as
purely implementing the nationally set
policy and they're the ones that set the
criteria in terms of it we're not
unoccupied and unfurnished so we we have
limited discretion in terms of how we
apply that locally
canta Stanley if if this is taking four
words national policy do they have a
description or we could use as to what
they consider substantially unfurnished
thank you I think we've sort of answered
that as best we can we can obviously
take away as we say and circulate some
more information and see if there is
anything more and set out in legislation
that determines that but my
understanding is to say it's a slightly
gray area and there is an element of
discretion in terms of how we sort of
apply that locally but we as I've said
we also collect some more information
that we have available after the meeting
council Stanny Thank You chairman could
you tell us how many properties are
livable and how many of those are
actually in bad disrepair and not not
really livable in in the way that we are
talking is that possible I don't have
the information to handle again I think
it's probably an element of subjectivity
in terms of how you would define those
two categories but certainly again I can
take that away and provide some
information after the meeting I see no
other members indicating so if I can
move to the recommendation item a on
page thirteen point two the council
Tech's empty homes premium be increased
as follows I won't read it all out is as
shown in the report is that agreed
members and paragraph B to apply the
council tax empty homes premium in all
cases that meet the criteria in a above
with the exception of the statutory
exemptions is that agree vendors
thank you that is sort of greed item 14
I think you're going to yes present this
Thank You chairman
so regulations require that each
District Council must establish and
maintain an independent regeneration
panel to review and make recommendations
on the remuneration scheme for members
of the district and parish town and town
councils the council's must have regard
to the advice of the panel but do not
have to implement its recommendations
the report of the independent
remuneration panel on district 8
district council remuneration is
appended and councils invite you to
consider recommendations 1 to 5 set out
on pages fourteen point six to fourteen
point nine thank you Jim wish to speak
on this item
just to say chairman on taking no part
in this debate and I should be
abstaining thank you Thank You council
mr. Mason Jim and I would like to ask a
question this is these are
recommendations for an independent
meaning panel is it that the council has
to take those as presented in that they
have to consider them as put forward is
there any opportunity for council to
amend them I've never come across them
being amended and all the time I've been
here but I feel inclined before we make
do we take a vote or debate it we should
know what the status is of the
remuneration panel's recommendations and
what the council cannot and cannot do I
think it is a recommendation before the
cap before members receive nning it's as
simple as that I think that is correct
isn't is it not
that's correct chairman councils should
have regard to the advice of the panel
but do not have to implement the
recommendations the question of
allowance levels are a matter for the
council as long as they have regard so a
panel have been giving advice Thank You
chairman councilor mountain Thank You
chairman the point I'm just asking about
is is in relation to point one four on
page fourteen point five with committee
chairmen it just strikes me that
although they're saying that all
committee chairmen should receive the
same amount I think it it seems fairly
clear the the chairman of Development
Committee is perhaps more time can that
there's more time consumed with being a
chairman of Development Committee than
so the chairman of Audit Committee and I
speak as a former chairman of Audit
Committee for for one year and yes there
our responsibilities involved with you
the chairman of Audit Committee is
responsible for four meetings a year the
chairman of Development Committee is
it's twelve you know twelve meetings at
least a year and I just think that
possibly should be taken into
consideration this is something I've
thought about before this came up but
just a point I'd like to raise but I
don't think this is before is this
evening well it's for consideration for
the future if members so decide
we have before I beg your pardon mr.
counselor mrs. Mason Thank You mr.
chairman as my husband says I have to
raise my hand higher so I read this
report with interest I know that over
the I think it's ten years if I recall
without going back to report the
allowances the basic allowances has
become being the same and we have a
situation there where we're proposing
them are the same I think the amount of
work done by some of the members of the
council has increased some of the
chairing has become probably we're
expecting slightly more and rightly so
of some of our chairs and sort of a
portfolio holders that said I look at
the two options before us we have stay
the same ten years down the line or we
have what they have come up with as a
proposal option two which increases the
basic allowance and I must declare I
have a slight interest in that because
it would affect me but it will affect
all of us so we all have an interest but
it does seem fair democratic and more
equitable I do like the way it's being
referred to the portions that are done
in Parliament's but more than anything
what we have with option two is a more
equitable distribution of funds but more
than that we have a saving and we've
just heard tonight of how difficult it
is and how much we want to raise money
you've just voted to put the council tax
up by two point nine eight percent yet
here a very small amount
I accept that but it is a saving and I
think where we can do is have a saving
we should affect a saving and I would
like to propose that we go with option
two
- mister Nezzer yep so I pick upon then
term please 14.8 the final paragraph on
220 paragraph 5 subparagraph 1 we talked
about overnight stays in London of 180
pound a night that seems very a very
high amount to me and I've got two
questions one is that how often do we
actually stay in lung in central London
and the second question is what do
officers get in equivalent so in other
words if an officer was sustained in
central London what were they again the
reason why I asked that is because organ
or other public sector organisations in
particular civil service the allowances
for MPs and administers can be tied to
the rights of senior civil servants
thank you
Thank You chairman in terms of the
number of claims I don't have figures
with me but there's not many and hasn't
been many in terms of officers
allowances these figures are historic
now in terms of they've been like this
for a number of years and my
understanding is that account was taken
of allowances for officers when they
were first introduced but I couldn't be
sure about that I'm just this point out
as it says at paragraph two point one
nine that yeah this would bring the
member allowances into line with the
officer allowances so they would be
consistent across the board so that the
proposed policy would bring it into line
with the office of policy
well we have a motion on the floor to
opt for option two all those in favor
[Music]
thank you all those against
that is that is carriage so on
can we come back to that in my counselor
couple and then I abstained as well and
myself yes Thank You chairman
the vote was 24 for 3 against thank you
sent for the voyage of doubt it covers
just see who how many abstained for five
abstentions five six six abstentions
so that says paragraph one so option two
is agreed yeah recommendation two as
shown in the report all those in favor
I'm on page fourteen point six okay I'll
read it out that the multiplier for the
allowance for independent persons and
parish members of the standards
committee members of the independent
remuneration panel member champions and
co-op tees be retained at ten percent of
the basic allowance for Rockford
district council members all those in
favor that's a great thank you
item three that the childcare and carers
allowances be retained at their current
levels and they're as follows then
they're set out in the report is that a
great members great thank you
paragraph four that the private car
allowance be increased from forty p to
forty-five people model in line with
HMRC rates and that other allowances
stay the same so that claims for
traveling expenses must be based on one
of the following and again that says set
out in the report on page fourteen point
seven is that agreed members kill it's
agreed item five that the rate of
allowances for breakfast lunch and
evening meals should be changed and the
t allowance deleted to keep them in line
with officer allowances which had
recently been amended so that
subsistence allowances are as follows
again as set out in the report is that
agreed members
it's the end of that item so we move now
to item 15 and I think thank you
remember this report deals with the
returning officers fees and arrangements
for elections its proposed that there'll
be no change to the returning officers
fee and the discretionary payment to
staff in the election office but it is
necessary to increase the fees paid to
start working in pulsations in order to
comply with the national minimum wage a
benchmarking exercise has been carried
out and new rates are set out in
Appendix one there is one amendment
apologies members in relation to poll
clock training which is shown in the
reporters being 30 pounds but that needs
to be 34 pounds to breed in line with
the presiding officer rate of 34 pounds
as reflected by the asterisk notation
and apologies for that that's a
typographical error where there are
blanks for the purposes of clarification
where there are blanks in the election
fees table that indicates that there is
no change and that the fee listed in the
left-hand column should remain and be
carried forward for the next financial
year thank you
Osito members wishing to speak so we'll
go straight to the recommendation
that it be agreed to retain the fees
paid to the returning officer at their
current level and as identified at
appendix 1 table age that agreed members
kill let it be agreed to retain the fees
for clerical allowance at their current
level and as identified as Appendix 1
that table B as that agreed members and
kill that the increased election fees be
agreed as set out in appendix 1 table C
for 2019 is that agree banders item 16
review of the polling districts and
polling places
thank you again chair members this is a
polling review carried out in accordance
with statutory requirements a
consultation was undertaken as set out
in the report and the proposed changes
are comprised within the table set in
Appendix B to that report members I need
to bring your attention to two changes
which have happened subsequent to the
conclusion of the consultation in
respect of the Hockley and Ashington
ward and the lodge ward which had been
proposed there would be no changes so
taking first please the Hockley and
Ashington ward following closure of the
consultation election colleagues were
approached by the greensward academy
which indicated it was no longer
prepared to be considered as a poll
station and then in fact had alternative
arrangements booked for the date of the
election accordingly I'm very grateful
to colleagues in the election office who
have worked tirelessly to find an
alternative venue and it is proposed
therefore that the poll station which is
a double poll station will be hotly
evangelical church which is just down
the road from these the school so it is
within walking
of the original polling station and is
sufficiently large to accommodate both
poll stations there will be some
amendments required to ensure that the
building can be used appropriately and
I'm confident that colleagues in the
election office will be able to make
sure those arrangements are undertaken
and duly publicized in addition the in
relation to Lodge Ward again election
colleagues receive notification from the
oaktree Children's Center which is
currently operated by the charity dr.
Barnardo's who indicated that it was not
compatible with the charitable
objectives of that organization for them
to allow the premises to be used for an
election and again I'm grateful to
colleagues in the election office who
have source an alternative venue out to
Raley Lodge and again that new venue is
capable of holding both poll stations
and so it is proposed there for members
that those two polling stations be used
in in deference to the ones that are
actually within the appendix thank you
you know just got one question cross and
Grange Park Road I know they're gonna be
holding it in the Travis Troy pop well
last year we hope we hope when they're
polling stations in the local bar but
we've got told that a public a public
house wasn't a suitable event so can you
just confirm that whether you're going
to be holding polling stations in pubs
or is it just a moment
whether apologies to counselor mrs. who
I'm not aware of the circumstances in
which that communication was given to
you there is no prohibition on using a
public house as a polling station or any
licensed premises as a polling station
the choice of using travelers joy on
this occasion was in preference to the
established Porter cabin which had been
used for very many years which was both
inconvenient and unaccommodating and
required a generator and oil to be
available on-site and that from a health
and safety perspective required offices
to actually top up the generator during
the course of the 15 hour Polian period
which on reflection I took the view that
to use the travelers joy pub was both a
saving to the council for not having to
rent a porter cabin but also was more
accommodating I'm grateful for embassies
are we raising that question because I
don't freak when pubs a lot really and
when I do I end it now to find that car
parks are definitively linked to people
buying provisions if you think from from
the pub meals drinks whatever and in
fact I went into one with the family at
the weekend and you had to put your
registration number in otherwise you
were subject to an external planting I
don't know much about the travellers joy
except that I was down there around nine
months ago and I I didn't park there we
didn't are there because I think there
are some prohibition on cost in which
case how's the council going to deal
with voters who want to turn up at a pub
and have to pay for parking
thank you if I can ask George Sullivan
who is my elections manager he was
present and has viewed all of the signs
as part of this process hello counselor
mr. Mason yeah just to advise there is a
car parking machine at the travellers
joy but it is three free parking on site
I can't remember the duration I believe
it's something like two maybe three
hours you do have to purchase a ticket
because there is an automated number
plate recognition camera that monitors
the vehicles entering and leaving that
carpark
so it is monitored but people will be
able to come and go for voting purposes
provided they both get the machine from
the story the ticket from the machine so
they won't have to actually pay to cast
their votes and certainly I'm just to
add to that thank you George as part of
this consultation any changes to
establish poll stations will be
well-publicized so that the voting
public is aware of changes and any
limitations on site
like I've got cast ahoy I'll come back
to you sorry huh
council ward councillor Hawaii
councillor Stanley councillor Mountain
okay
Thank You general yeah I'm a bit
concerned actually about large water
going into the Lord I'm trying to
visualize how this is actually gonna
work I know it was quite difficult when
we were at at the center down by Grove
wood it did work well in the separate
rooms and I'm very disappointed that
they have decided they don't want it
there now but I'm a little bit anxious
about how it's going to work at the
lodge where how busy that place is you
know with lunches and all the various
things like that yes counselor well
thank you
they traveled they went down to see
Raley Lodge earlier this week and there
is a dedicated entrance to one side of
the premises if you are facing the
premises it's to the left-hand side near
the conservatory and that allows direct
access to where the polling station will
be located there'll be a dedicated area
within there that will be used
it also has level access for disabled
voters to come and go from the carpark
briefly it's just on the fact obviously
this this will be a double polling
station then will it just be one
entrance and how is that gonna work out
with the two areas
we we had envisaged using one entrance
for voters coming in and out but it may
well be that if necessary there is the
separate entrance for voters to leave
should that route prove to be congested
it's I think it's fair to say that we
have had double poll stations with
single entry before it is a question of
signage and ensuring that that Paul
clocks are able to help voters to
establish as they enter the premises
which polling station they should
actually be voting out Council mr. Hoyer
thank you Kevin just to to bits with the
first part is about the whole be
community center today I'm quite
surprised that they said they're unable
to to break their first interview for
one day a year and when I've spoken to
them they facing quite happy tree in the
future I know there is such as last year
because of the lateness of the change of
the venue then can you confirm that you
have spoken to them recently
I see it's May or June about this and
that reconfirmed that that's the first
bit the second bit is taking for counsel
mr. Mosca craziness I think it's totally
unacceptable to use the travellers joy
with the car park in its current
configuration people but could be going
into that car park it has enough
automatic number recognition automatic
number plate recognition mail he did not
have that last year if people go in
there do not get a ticket they would be
fined and I think this is going to be a
big problem if that is happening and I
think that that cannot be used either in
the public self or as a poor cabbies
unless that is addressed because people
will be getting fined for voting and
also just in relation to her very
quickly she said isn't he it's just
about the the use of pubs I mean there's
an equality on diversity implications
there have you
has there been consideration and run of
any regions which may not welcome that
they're members going on to licensed
premises Methodist for instance we've
done its don't free thank you
did counsel mr. Hoyt to deal with the
first point we did approach halbridge
Community Center and they have regular
bookings on a Thursday which are a dance
club and a bowls club they asked those
hirers if they would be willing to
reschedule or maybe cancel those events
on the days when there are elections one
of the hirez was willing to agree to
that point but one of them was not
unfortunately so for that reason we were
unable to use the community center so it
was approached okay with regard to the
car parking arrangements at the
travelers joy the issue has been
highlighted to me by the manager of the
premises when we went down to see the
venue so we are aware of it what we will
do is we can ensure that our polling
staff do brief those persons coming in
to vote so they are aware that they need
to purchase a ticket
there are signage ease all over the
venue as well making people aware that
they need to purchase a ticket or get a
free ticket I should say an equality
impact assessment has been carried out
throughout the consultation we have
spoken with members of equality's
communities there hasn't been any
objection to the use of licensed
premises clearly the premises the room
in which the poll booths will be located
is not going to be serving alcohol at
the same time so it's just I do have
couple support seeking at least on the
basis of the travelers tour car park I
really do think there's a barrier to
people going in to vote Thank You
councillor Stanley
Thank You chairman weed reflection to
the travelers joy I believe you have to
purchase a ticket is that going to be
redeemed at the bar or is the council
going to redeem that for the residents
thank you just to answer your question
councillor Stanley you obtained the
ticket which is free but you do have to
enter your vehicle registration to get
that ticket but as I said earlier it is
free for I believe it's something like
two or maybe three hours so you don't
actually purchase the ticket yeah okay
thank you chairman just again on that
car park point I just wonder if the
council has made any contact with to see
if there's any way that that can be
suspended the whole number plate
recognition that the whole parking
process charge or no charge whether the
mechanisms can be suspended on the
actual day of the elation thank you so
we'll make those inquiries however I
would imagine that most voters will not
be using a full two to three hours
on-site and so I'm expecting that
problem to be quite minimal yeah I mean
the point is it's in layman's terms it's
a faff but you know the idea that you
have to get a ticket
whether or not it's free or whatever
it's still a block it's something it's a
hurdle that is in the way of you know
well-intentioned residents going out to
vote and I'm just thinking has is it
possible for the council to start a
conversation with the ticket company to
see if it can be suspended on the day of
the election thank you
Thank You counselor mounting yeah we'll
certainly look into it will contact the
premises and see if that is feasible
okay thank you children are they going
to be two rooms for the voting at Riley
Lodge as they have been in the past when
it's been a double station we are
planning to use one room at the venue as
we believe it will be large enough to
accommodate both the polling stations
there the tables will be moved out of
the way to allow a larger floor space to
accommodate everything then I assume
you're using the conservatory is is that
what you're actually saying are you
actually using the conservatory of that
exceptional I'm very familiar with it so
is it the conservatory only that's being
used which is the restaurant part not
the pub part it is the area directly
inside that door that I mentioned
earlier before you go down to the
conservatory the reason being there are
steps down to the conservatory which
could potentially impede those with
pushchairs
or anyone in a wheelchair
counselor mrs. Mason Aaron I didn't
think this was gonna take long I just
like to come back to the travelers joy
and I think counselor mark mountings
suggestion if we can have the parking
recognition numbers switched off of the
day would be ideal
however if not it does concern me
someone because anything that impales or
deters someone from voting is we
shouldn't be doing it and it is putting
a barrier in place albeit that barrier
isn't costly it is a barrier but what
concerns me is the idea presumably of
putting your number in is that they can
recognize it and not charge your car but
some people were being a rush and if
they make an error they're going to get
charged we should have a policy on that
because if we can't get those machines
turned off effectively we will be
charging people for voting which is
totally unacceptable
so I think that needs to be looked at I
appreciate it's difficult I mean the
venue if it wasn't for the parking I
think would be ideal for its location
but the parking concern is a barrier to
me because it's a barrier to someone
walking in and you have said that your
approach people as they come in
we're sure it would be better to
approach them when they go out because
again it's a barrier you'll get people
running back out to their cars so I do
think that needs to be thought out very
carefully if councillor Mel mountains
suggestion can't be enacted thank you
and a policy should someone get charged
thank you two points although some
estimates may already address one of
them I think the placing barriers or
reasons for people not to vote should
should be discouraged and as well as the
car parking issue I think whilst I
welcome the clarification on the rooms
themselves in the travellers joy or the
lodge not serving alcohol I think
to walk through an environment where
alcohol is served in order to get to
your polling station would also be a
barrier for people who against that for
personal reasons religious religion I
would just like to clarify that the
entrances would be wouldn't take them
through and buying the wild cards being
served as well as the environment itself
not serving alcohol thank you Thank You
chairman I just need to understand where
you're actually going to put the polling
station in the lodge when you go
straight in through the front entrance
you either go to the right which is the
main bar you go to the left which is the
entrance to the restaurant
you've got the foyer to the restaurant
and a small bar is that foyer going to
be the double station that foyer I need
to understand this now the entrance as
I've said is just to a separate door to
the side of the main entrance that leads
just above that can swear the
conservatory is located so if you were
facing Raley Lodge I know the area in
question they as you say leads into like
a foyer area then you've got a bar to
the left hand side and another area to
the right hand side a dining area but
before you go into that entrance as I
say there is an entranceway to the left
slightly nearer to the carpark and that
is the entrance envisaged for voters to
go in and that the area will be inside
there
we we've carried out a site visit
I'm happy for us to go back and have
another look if we can only fit in one
Paul station at Raley Lodge then we will
continue to use the other site at
Greenwood primary school so yeah
probably
Greenwood primary school oh I beg your
pardon
yes grow great yes so Grove would
primary school so we could have two
separate pull stations we we have shied
away from using the school because again
they've indicated a reluctance to use
school premises but if I am not
satisfied that the the site really
largely is suitable for both polling
stations then the law enables me to to
require that the school make itself
available but I really want to do that
only in exceptional circumstances so
we'll take another look and we'll review
that but we absolutely at this stage or
are looking at Raley Lodge for at least
one Paul station
councillor Carol I apologize I may have
put it forward as a point of concern I
was actually a clarification on whether
we I don't know the large layout I don't
know the travellers Joey layout I was
just looking for clarification as so we
were proposing that people walk through
environments while I was being served in
order to get to their polling station
thank you in the case of travellers joy
there is one entrance into the venue so
there would be interesting that will
bring you in front of the bar
potentially where people would go to the
right hand side where the voting polling
station is designated to be in the case
of Rayleigh Lodge the entrance I'm
intending to use separates voters from
going near the bar area in that case as
it has a dedicated entrance that is
suitable
okay
counter mrs. roat Thank You chairman I'm
in respective Lodge ward so if we have
or used the shore start Center and then
Rayleigh Lodge that then makes them
three polling stations in Lodge which
isn't ideal in effect because we've got
Methodist Church will be the third one
so that doesn't make it ideal really
having three for one ward the only way I
could support Lodge is if you did go
back and have a look and make sure that
room is okay because in fairness it
makes lots of lots of sense with the car
park car parks a lot bigger we do have
problems down at the school we've had to
have Marshalls down there in the past
that you know especially at school times
so as long as that room you're really
happy with that but I really would like
you to go back to that because I don't
think it'll be a problem if it's too
small
thank you well members can I can I
suggest we proceed with the
recommendation but we add the words
subject to officers undertaking an
agreed review in relation to the
travellers joy and Raley Lodge would
that be acceptable
you okay on that basis we will formally
go to the recommendation that the final
proposals for changes to bowling
arrangements in the district has
summarized in paragraphs four point two
to four point five we agreed subject to
officers undertaking agreed and agreed
review in relation to the travellers joy
and Raley Lodge said agreed members
thank you item 17 discretionary business
rates relief retail relief Pollock
policy thank you yes the purpose of this
report is to agree that the new retail
rate relief policy as attached to
Appendix A to the report to be agreed
the government announced in its autumn
budget in October that it would provide
for our business rates retail relief
occupied retail properties with a
rateable value of less than 51,000
pounds and the value of that relief
would be one third of their bill subject
to state aid limits in order to enact
this policy we must adopt a local scheme
and in accordance with the discussion
area rate relief powers contained within
section 47 of the local government
finance act we must decide when relief
should be granted relief under this
policy would only be granted for the
financially is 2019-20 and 2020 21 and
the cost of the scheme would be fully
reimbursed by central government so it's
not expecting it so via any net cost to
us as a local council so given that yes
I would propose the recommendation ducks
we implement the scheme as set out in
the report
it's there to greet members thank you
and the final item on the agenda is the
responses to business rates retention
reform and relative needs and resources
consultations and the recommendation is
that the council submit the responses to
the consultations as appended to this
report does anyone wish to speak on this
in which case is that recommendation
agreed members thank you John at the end
of the last meeting I stood up and
thanked John Bosco Frawley service and
they did it at the wrong time because I
forgot there was a meeting this week as
well now take this opportunity planking
John now making a point of record for
all the service that he's given to us
all the help that he's given us and in
his personal friendship as well which I
very much value so thank you John for
all you have done for us and good luck
into the future from all of us
I would also like to reiterate the
council cut laws remarks but in addition
I would like to thank John for the
support and guidance guidance that he's
given to me over the last few months
during my period as chairman being very
much valued and I wish him all the best
in the future and thank him on behalf of
the council for 23 years services it mr.
chairman can I just thank members for
their kind words tonight the kind
messages and cards first time I might
you might hear someone crying on tape
rather than talking but thank you and
I've worked with members in other
councils and your great members thank
you and I know you serve the community
in spite of that pro rata rule so thank
you thank you well members I now close
the meeting at 9:15 thank you all for
your attendance and a safe journey home
members please be upstanding while
Chairman and Managing Director leave the
chamber